hi my name is jacob mcphail and i'm an r
d scientist at stress mark biosciences
and i'm going to tell you today about
our efforts in characterizing pathogenic
protein aggregates for utilization as
molecular tools to accelerate
neurodegenerative disease research it's
quite the mouthful of the title
um so
we're based in victoria bc on the west
coast of canada we're not actually in
vancouver here we're on vancouver island
so we're north of seattle and west of
vancouver
there is a beautiful shot of our harbor
there and at stress mark we produce life
science reagents including proteins
conjugates and immunoassays and in
recent years we've had a particular
focus on pathological proteins involved
in neurodegenerative diseases
so
alzheimer's and parkinson's diseases are
the most common neurodegenerative
disorders alzheimer's is the sixth
leading cause of death in the u.s with
recent estimates actually suggesting
this is closer to third in those age 65
plus
this is becoming a greater issue as the
population ages as you could imagine
and despite the significant impacts on
health and
economics even there are no cures known
so
the key thing here is that both of these
diseases are characterized by the
presence of plaques in the brain
and these consist of protein aggregates
which include the key proteins alphas
nuclei tau
and amyloid beta which i'm going to talk
about to
an extent today
so alpha nucleon tau and ibera share a
common pathological mechanism and this
is going to be key to my talk today so
essentially these these monomers are
fairly flexible
freely soluble proteins and
during the pathology of this these form
these oligomers and eventually
these insoluble fibrils which
um form the the core of these these
plaques observed in these
neurodegenerative diseases and uh here
at stress mark we seek to generate these
different aggregated states in vitro so
that we can use these as research tools
and disease models and drug discovery
so
talking about alphanuclein first
alphanuclein normally in the cell
regulates synaptic vesicle trafficking
in neuron so here on the left you can
see
on a membrane it does have some alpha
helical structure
but it also does have this flexible tail
and this is going to be important later
in the talk when i talk about
serine 129 and its phosphorylation which
is indicative of
parkinson's disease pathology
so alphanucleon
normally in solution is an unfolded
monomer and it associates with these
synaptic vesicle membranes
to exert its functions
and essentially what happens and and
there have been many different
sort of inducers that have been studied
of
what causes this process but what we
know happens is these flexible monomers
form um these oligomers
as well as these um
large insoluble fibrils so
something causes this aggregation and
these proteins you know pack on each
other
and essentially parkinson's disease is
characterized by alphas nuclear
aggregation into these toxic oligomers
and fibrils
so here at stress mark we've generated
several types of alphanucleon preformed
fibrils in vitro so these are
recombinant proteins that
we've been able to drive into pre
to study its its effects
in animal models so
there are several types of different
fibrils um
related to the endotoxin level that's
present and also mutation so
familial parkinson's a53t mutation that
actually drives early onset parkinson's
and these sort of more soluble filaments
here
so looking at these
these alpha nucleon preformed fibrils
will actually seed monomers into fibrils
so monomers are those flexible states
and if you add some of these pre-formed
relatively insoluble fibrils it will
actually induce
further
formation of fibrils so here how we look
at that is this bioflavon t molecule
when it binds to fibrils its emission at
492 nanometers
is increased
so on the right here is an alphanucleon
seeding assay and what you'll see in
terms of just relative fluorescence
units on the y-axis is over time these
type 1 fibrils which
are formed with a little bit more
endotoxin present
have a much larger signal and seed
monomer and generate more of this tht
signal a lot faster and to a greater
degree over time versus type 2 fibrils
the the line in the middle there um
despite there being the presence is
there under em for both types of fibrils
so they are forming but something is
different in their structure that's
affecting the thyroid and t binding
so taking these preformed fibrils and
actually testing their effects in mice
first looking at the
type 1 preform fibrils and these
actually induce parkinson's
phosphoserine 129 pathology in a mouse
brain so
remember i mentioned when i was talking
about the alphanucleon molecule it has
that flexible tail that
in parkinson's disease becomes
phosphorylated when it packs into these
fibrils and these these aggregates so
this is a single unilateral injection
into the dorsal striatum uh 30 days
prior so one injection from one side and
what you'll
take monomer
which has
okay the same level of low of endotoxin
as the preformed fibrils
and you look at different concentrations
here on the top there's not really any
signal for the phosphoserine 129.
on the bottom row here
you'll see sort of this slight
browning color on these mouse brain
slices indicating that
phosphoserine 129 is now present
after injection of these fibrils
and
remember because these are recombinant e
coli express proteins the alpha nuclei
and preformed fibrils are not
phosphorylated prior to injection so
this is suggesting this is actually
initiating
phosphoserine 129 parkinson's related
pathology in these mice
and
essentially here's a summary of
several of these mice that these
experiments were attempted on and as you
can see
this phosphoserine 129 pathology was not
observed in any of the mice that were
injected with just monomer
and
in preformed fibrils at the lower
concentration most of the mice showed
this pathology and at the higher
concentration all of them did
so um
although there may be a small level of
endotoxin presence in the monomers and
the preformed fibrils
this control showing monomer is is
indicating that the endotoxin isn't
having the effect it's actually the
preformed fibril that's in that's
initiating that pathology
um and looking on the the left side of
of this table here
ipsilateral so that's where the
injection happened
you'll see that that shows the pathology
and the preformed favorables but also
the contralateral hemisphere so
indicating that within the 30 days
after this injection
that the phosphoserine 129 pathology is
actually
distributing throughout the brain away
from the injection site so it's not just
occurring
where these fibrils were injected
so i'm diving a little bit deeper into
this
so
so these are um you know histo
chemistry experiments um looking a
little bit closer than just the over
um and what you'll see is is so these
now where we're doing
um single bilateral and intra striatal
injections and what you'll see is
monomer over 120 days
isn't showing any uh phosphoserine 129
pathology but pre-formed fibrils
especially after 60 days and 120 days
there's a lot of phosphorylated serine
129 there
over time
and then this is where the injection
happened in the in this triad
looking at the parietal cortex which
is distal from where the injection site
is you'll see again monomer over 120
days we're not seeing any
dark signal for
phosphoserine 129 and i should indicate
that the
antibody used here is is phosphoserine
129 specific so it won't
show a signal if there's no
phosphoserine there it doesn't just
non-specifically bind to all this
nuclein it only binds to
this phosphorylation site
and
these preformed fibrils again we're
distal from the injection site we're
seeing pathology spreading here
over 120
days looking at the substantia
[ __ ] so
this is
a pretty critical region in parkinson's
disease where it's a highly dopaminergic
region and these dopaminergic neurons in
here
die off
in parkinson's disease so it is really a
critical
area to be looking at and you'll see
again monomer is not inducing
phosphoserine 129 pathology over 120
days but preformed fibril is
um
so i think that's pretty strong evidence
that these fibrils are are initiating
this
pathology here
looking at actual
dopamine levels so how is his brain
dopamine
affected by these fibrils
you'll see
monomer over 120 days here and we're
looking at the dopamine nanograms per
milligram of total protein determined
by lcms so using mass spec
and you'll see monomer over time there's
there's no change in the levels of
dopamine
but in the preformed fibrils especially
after 120 days
there is quite a significant reduction
in the amount of dopamine around
and we also did this mass spec with
dopamine metabolites
and found the same effect
so moving on to a rat model
we essentially find the same thing so
um
looking at the phosphoserine 129
pathology
again monomer is not inducing anything
over 120 days pre-formed fibrils you're
getting a pretty strong presence of
phosphoserine 129
in the striatum where the injection is
again looking at the parietal cortex so
so distal to the injection site
we're not getting anything with monomer
but these pre-formed fibrils
again are strongly inducing
phosphoserine 129 pathology
and
the same thing in the substantia
[ __ ] so
preformed fibrils pretty strong response
even after uh 30 days post-injection
in these highly dopaminergic neurons
so um
again same looking at dopamine the
lcms shows that there is quite a
significant reduction
um
you know even after 60 days in a rat
model of dopamine production
and again similar trends observed for
dopamine metabolites
so these are images from dr rihanna leak
at
duquesne university and this is actually
showing one of these other tools that
we've developed
and that is an ato dye conjugated fibril
so
we have several wavelengths of these
available we're looking at ato 647
and this is basically showing in actual
primary rat hippocampal neurons
that
they appear to be uptaking these fibrils
so the fibrils or or some
piece of them is is being uptaken by um
these rat neurons so here um map2
is showing it's basically a pan neuronal
marker so it's showing where the neuron
outlines are and what you'll see in in
so that's in red and in sort of gray
here is the ato 647 dye which is
associated with
um directly covalently linked to the
fibrils and you'll see it's sort of
concentrated within the neurons there
indicating potential
uptake there
and what we really want to look at next
is if we can actually
start to see transmission from neuron to
neuron of these these fibrils
okay so i'll just remind you um again we
have this monomeric state and sort of
the healthy cells these oligomers that
form in these fibrils
the females are are very interesting in
in terms of their their seating and and
their visibility in
both alzheimer's and parkinson's
plaques but
um these oligomers are actually
thought to be the more toxic
structure so um
we have been looking at those as well um
more recently and
we have successfully generated alphas
nucleon oligomers in vitro so
the first ones we were able to make are
these dopamine induced oligomers so
you'll see these are
globular structures you know 20 to 30
nanometers if they're not clumped
together here on the left
under em and
the dopamine is physiologically relevant
because when you think of parkinson's
disease and and the death of
dopaminergic neurons these are neurons
that have a high concentration of
dopamine and alphanucleon is working in
these synaptic vesicles which contain
dopamine so it's not a huge stretch to
think that there may be some role of
dopamine here
and
we are able to induce these oligomers
with the presence of dopamine
and actually just recently
we've developed these native oligomers
with no inducer and we're pretty excited
to
start working with those and they're an
excellent control for the dopamine
induced oligomers as well
so
here's our initial data from the the
dopamine
oligomers and we have shown that
they do seem to be more neurotoxic than
the preformed fibrils
so looking at primary mouse cortical
neuron viability
and we're measuring this by
mitochondrial dehydrogenase mtt activity
basically if the neurons are healthy
their mitochondria are healthy they're
able to to
degrade basically this this yellow dye
into this this purple crystal and you
can read that out in an assay and what
you'll see here um on the the left so
um that's the percent
for to vehicle control so the vehicle
control here is is up at 100
and you'll see
several of the different types of
fibrils here
and they do
coronal viability by
about 25 to to a significant degree
um monomer on its own is is not
affecting the the viability of these
neurons
and then on the right here you see the
dopamine oligomers and they are
significantly more toxic so you know
less than 50 percent viability um
compared to the 75 ish viability from
the preformed fibrils so we have found
that they are indeed more toxic
and we are
currently investigating the native
oligomers
just to confirm that
the dopamine isn't having any effect
itself
so that was
it for alpha nucleon i also want to
talk about tau a little bit here so
tau functions to stabilize microtubules
so microtubules are
pretty negatively charged
tau has a high pi it's it's more
positively charged it stabilizes these
microtubules and
through
some mechanism and and many different
have been studied uh
when tau is not bound to
these microtubules and again we're
talking about a very flexible um
relatively unstructured protein in
solution it also similar to alphanucleon
starts to oligomerize
and then it eventually forms these
perihelical filaments and these
neurofibrillary neurofibrillary tangles
present in the
plaques in alzheimer's disease
now
tau is normally regulated through
phosphorylation so the more
phosphorylated it is
the less it's going to bind to the
negatively charged microtubules it's a
regulatory mechanism
but probably the best studied
mechanism is this hyper phosphorylation
of tau that occurs drives it away from
microtubules
and then really facilitates this
oligomerization and
eventual
um sort of fibril filament formation
here
and in alzheimer's and parkinson's this
hyperphosphorylated tau
is present and that's sort of a hallmark
of these diseases
so we have been able to generate several
isoforms of the tau preformed fibrils
several
relevant mutations clinical mutations
related to alzheimer's disease
several different sizes so 2n4r is is
the full length
tau isoform k-18 is a is a more
truncated fragment as is dgae
and recently we've also been able to
make the wild type full-length tau
fibrils
and in general
some because we're working with
recombinant e coli material and there's
no phosphorylation
a scaffold such as heparin is needed to
induce large scale aggregation
of these larger constructs
and
also recently we've
been able to generate this baculovirus
sf9
expressed tau which
we've confirmed with
mass spec that has over 30 sites of
phosphorylation so
hyper phosphorylated one could say
and these will actually aggregate on
their own so the phosphorylation is
really driving this um
self aggregation
um without a scaffold so these don't
actually need a heparin
inducer so here you'll see the tht
seating assay looking at relative
fluorescence units over time you can see
the
monomer on its own is is actually
forming fibrils
and
also um is seated so the higher green
line there um
so
yeah so it's pretty cool that they form
um on their own without a heparin
inducer and we're really excited to test
these out in
some mouse models
so
so far we've tried the tau k team
preformed fibrils
injected into mouse hippocampus
and
now we're looking at and again with with
an antibody
uh tau serine 202 threonine 205 which
has been shown to drive tau aggregation
and
what you'll see here after
injection of these fibrils into
hippocampus is
this these tangle like inclusions appear
here and the inset here is the negative
control so it's you know
nice and clear there's there's no
aggregate
detected by antibody observed there and
and in the other uh boxes here you can
see that that sort of
um
those tangle like inclusions
um and this is nine weeks post injection
so we are indicating we are initiating
a sort of alzheimer's-like pathology
here
and again these are not phosphorylated
before they're
injected into
the mouse model
so
we also have generated
tau oligomers and this is pretty recent
data we have
and
using arachidonic acid so arachidonic
acid is a fatty acid and it plays key
roles key signaling roles in neurons and
it's actually the second most abundant
fatty acid in the brain
so
basically in the presence of of
arachidonic acid tau will form these
nice globular oligomers here on the left
in a short incubation
and what you'll actually notice if you
look on the right here
not only are
there more oligomers around but they
start to elongate even and these are all
still soluble so
um
will these proceed to sort of a
protofilament and a peridolical filament
eventually possibly but we're pretty
excited to test out these new tau
oligomers in
cell cultures and and mouse models to
look at their toxicity relative to
preform fibrils and and pathology
induction
finally we also have started working
with a beta peptide so
it's a key component in
neurodegenerative diseases both
parkinson's and alzheimer's
and essentially what happens here is you
have this this transmembrane protein
that is cleaved by
various enzymes to release this small
soluble peptide
that very quickly aggregates and forms
these beta amyloid
plaques which are present in
both alzheimer's and parkinson's
fibril deposits
and
this is normally in the synapses of
neurons this is occurring and um
so it's it's it's relevant whether this
is occurring before alzheimer or before
um
tower alpha nuclean and inducing that
but that's definitely a possibility but
i think at the end of the day it's going
to be a combination of factors so it's
important to look at
all of these different proteins and
their oligomers and fibrils
on their own
so we have recently generated these a
beta 1 to 42 so those are the amino
acids
fibrils from a synthetic peptide
so what you'll see here on the left is
a scs-page
western plot with the 6010 antibody that
will detect
any
a beta
and
looking at the gel here monomer you just
get this this nice clean
um
signal from monomer protein down there
at five kilo daltons it's four and a
half
um and then in the fibrils
you actually see um on the gel here um
this formation at the
in the well and at the very top of of
the gel here so indicating a very large
size um these fibrils are forming and on
the right you'll see sort of
three different types that we have
um in development and we're continuing
to characterize these and
are looking forward to testing these in
in models as well
finally we've also been able to generate
um a beta oligomers from that synthetic
peptide so again here on the left
sds page western blot with the 6010
antibody
you'll see on um so the molecular weight
ladders on the very left lane the second
lane over you'll see this sort of faint
smear um of 37 kilobones up
indicating that oligomers are actually
forming here and more obvious is the
formation of these dimers and trimers
around
15 kilo daltons on this gel here
and on the right you'll see
those nice globular oligomers forming so
we're
pretty excited to test out the toxicity
of
these eight beta constructs as well
so
key takeaways overall alpha nucleon tau
fibrils generated in vitro will seed
additional febriles in vitro
as well as induce hallmarks of
parkinson's and alzheimer's pathology in
both mouse and wrap models
so they represent pretty cool tools to
study
the disease initiation and progression
in these
models
alpha nucleon oligomers
which we generate in vitro have an
increased neurotoxicity compared to
fibrils
and we're also really excited about the
tau and a beta ligamers that we've
developed
and are now
looking into
so our key next steps here are we would
love to demonstrate neurons neuron
transmission of of these in vitro
aggregates
in a model to actually show the
sort of spreading of pathology that we
think is occurring based on the
phosphoserine
being detected in all different parts of
the brain away from the injection site
and then we also want to fully
characterize toxicity and pathology of
our different oligomers relative to the
fibrils
so um i'd like to acknowledge
ariel
our present ceo for really organizing
and finding funding for this work
kristin has been a lab tech
working on r d of these new oligomers as
well as vicky sophie kenji
and alex for all the work they've done
on on the fibrils and and
the atto uh die conjugated preformed
fibrils were done by kenji so
i'm happy to take any questions
regarding this talk directly to my email
i wish it was a person that i can answer
in person but
that's the times that we live in right
now
uh so with that um i'll just leave you
with our last slide here if you're
looking for any more information on our
fibrils or oligomers which are coming up
really soon
for alpha nucleon tau a beta sod one and
ttr there's a whole bunch of other
proteins we're also working on
yeah so that's it thank you for
listening